[Music]
it is of no use to object to this
freedom which places any and every kind
of content and the universal passive
medium of duty and knowing by
maintaining that another content ought
to have been placed in it for whatever
content it be it contains the blemish of
determinate nests
what you're doing is free determinate
nests which pure knowing can
disdainfully reject or equally can
accept every content because it is
determinate stands on the same level as
any other even if it does seem to be
characterized by the elimination in it
of the element of particularity it may
seem that sense in the actual case duty
in general is sundered into an
antithesis and thereby into the
antithesis of individuality and
universality the duty whose content is
the universal itself directly contains
the nature of pure duty and form and
content are thus completely in accord it
might seem then that action for the
general good is to be preferred to
action for the good of the individual
but this Universal Duty is simply what
already exists as an absolute substance
as law and right and is valid on its own
account independently of the individuals
knowledge and conviction not to mention
his own immediate interest it is
therefore precisely against the form of
that duty that morality in general is
directed but as regards its content that
too is a determinate content insofar as
the general good as opposed to the good
of the individual consequently its law
is one from which conscience knows
itself to be absolutely free and it
gives itself the authority to add to and
take from to neglect as well as fulfill
it
then again the above distinction between
duty to the individual and duty to the
universal is in accordance with the
nature of the antithesis is such not
something definitely fixed the truth is
rather that what the individual does for
himself also contributes to the general
good the more he has made provision for
himself not only is there a greater
possibility of his being of service to
others but his actual existence itself
consists only in his being and living in
content
others his individual enjoyment
essentially has the meaning of putting
what is his own at the disposal of
others and of helping them to obtain
their enjoyment therefore in the
fulfillment of duty to individuals and
so to oneself the duty to the individual
is also fulfilled any weighing and
comparing of duties which might be made
here would be tantamount to calculating
the advantage of crewing to the
universal from an action but firstly the
result would be that morality would be
made dependent on the necessary
contingency of insight and secondly it
is precisely the essence of conscience
to have no truck with this calculating
and weighing of duties and to make its
own decision without reference to any
such reasons
paragraph 645 is a rather long ish one
and it's also a very important one to
look at closely as we're proceeding
through this morality section you notice
that there's reference to what has just
been discussed in the previous
paragraphs particularly in the one just
preceding it 644 what we're going to
talk about in just a moment as the
blemish of determinate nests will come
back to that very very soon and expand
on that but it's also an important
turning point because there's a sort of
realization on the part of the
determinate spirit that is morality and
I say that in somewhat of a facetious
way because when we think about the
morality that's being discussed here in
this section as you know so many people
have commented and as you may have
suspected as you're reading through it
what we're talking about here is not
merely conscient morality but a what we
can call conch and esque morality a sort
of on the one hand sort of a reductive
attitude towards Kant and the kind of
moral orientation that he not only
articulates but also represents on the
one hand sort of a simplification of it
which is what you need to do in order to
actually make it useful and applicable
on the other hand sort of a hyper
conscious ation of it as Hegel thinks
through some of the implications of what
it was that the account was bringing to
the table and let's come back to the
first one and then this is all before we
get into the text itself so what can we
say about about conch and morality it
stresses universality allgemeine Heights
right and we noticed that that plays a
major role within this this paragraph
anything that is going to be genuinely
moral has to be stripped of its
determinate content and abstracted as
much as possible into
some very general ideas and you notice
if you if you know your Conte that the
categorical imperative itself has to
take on several different formulations
which are all supposed to be essentially
you know on the same page with each
other but we can explore and see that
there could be some problems with that
but the idea is that on the one hand
this is what's running through any
genuinely moral being whether they've
read philosophy or not and on the other
hand its articulated in its deepest in
its most rigorous fashion in the works
of the person who followed out this
stuff working with a you might say
purified Faculty of Reason purifying
itself in the process that's a rather
dynamic aspect to it to Kant's work and
these are all supposed to map onto each
other and Hegel comes along and
essentially in this morality section
points out to us over and over and over
again it's not that simple you cannot
get away from what here he's calling the
blemish of determinate nacelle the thing
that's wrong with it the the flaw
dervish dimmed height Mishima is making
something not just actual but
particularized saying here's what we're
doing and it could be done by providing
context as when we talk about the
circumstances of an action or a choice
right we explored all these things much
earlier in all of these qualifications
that can be said about the moral action
the Honda the comportment
but that's what's really being discussed
here and that winds up being the scandal
the stumbling block of this approach to
morality that is not just that of Kant
but of so many other Enlightenment
thinkers as well so let's take up the
text now he says it is no use to object
to this freedom which places any
and every kind of content in the
universal passive of duty flicked right
and knowing this and by maintaining that
another content ought to have been
placed in it for whatever content it be
it contains the blemish of determinist
from which pure knowing now notice what
he says
pure knowing is free determinate miss
which pure knowing can disdainfully
reject or equally can accept so pure
knowing is quite powerful here in
relation to the determinant mnestheus of
the particular duty the duty of the
particular person in these contexts in
this situation right and so the
objection that can be made is quite
simply this why did you focus on this
instead of on this and here we might
take a little bit of a digression and
think about some of the the things that
happen in our own time that also did
happen in in Hegel's time think about
what we've come to call what about ISM
where somebody says yeah we got a moral
problem here somebody should have done
this but instead they did this and then
somebody else comes along and says okay
what about this you know and you can
imagine them saying it that kind of
stupid goofy tone of voice because it is
really a stupid thoughtless way of using
your faculty reason right it's done
really usually for ideological reasons
very often driven by emotional needs and
shows a kind of deceptiveness or a lack
of soft reflectiveness on the part of
the person employing it and what about
ism is essentially just substituting one
content in place of another in order to
nullify all of them it's it's really a
form of what Hagel would here would call
skepticism in the phenomenology there
you can go back to that section and
check that off if you want but we can
also say that one could do this in a
more genuine way and say well wait a
second you know you're focusing on this
but this really is important over
here hey you're leaving this out that's
not the same thing as what about ISM
it's more earnest or honest if we want
to use categories that have been coming
up throughout the reason and the spirit
section describing orientations of
people now the problem is once you start
going down that that you know course any
content is as good as any other content
it's totally up to pure knowing the
subject in this case to decide which one
they want to focus on and so really it's
no good objection to say well you know
this is determinate that so we're not
going to focus on that so he goes on and
he says every content because it is
determinate stands on the same level as
any other even if it does seem to be
characterized by the elimination in it
of the element of particularly now here
is where the turning point comes right
because Hegel is is showing us his hand
at this point what's the hand well if we
want to look ahead what we're gonna see
here is at first a prioritization of the
universal over the individual or the
particular right the universal is what
gets us out of this merely particular
merely determinate way of looking at
things and here again you might think of
Kant and you might think of what he says
in the groundwork about categorical
imperatives why is it that a categorical
imperative is the only possible source
of morality
well because any hypothetical
imperatives anything that is conditioned
right the if-then in the hypothetical
imperative is a set of conditions if you
want to be happy think about you know
the Maxim's that fall under councils of
prudence then you ought to do this and
this and this everybody does want to be
happy but can't says that can't be the
source of morality if you want to
accomplish this thing now we're getting
to what he calls rules of skill
all right less general more particular
well then you know how to do this so you
know if you don't want to be in debt
then you ought to save some money each
month and don't put everything into
banks because you know maybe interest
isn't isn't that effective some of it
needs to go into mutual funds some into
real estate etc etc you know we have all
this sort of financial planning stuff
constants that has nothing to do with
morality morality must be totally
universal so what we're going is a
reversal where the particular assumes an
important role and we're also seeing an
unveiling where the universal isn't
quite so universal and pure as we make
it out to me so let's see how he does
this he says it may seem that since in
the actual case duty in general is
surrendered is sundered into an
antithesis and antithesis here Gagan
Zots we could say contradiction as well
if we wanted to we don't have to insist
on this there isn't a synthesis the
thesis antithesis synthesis to look for
in this so don't want the word
antithesis trip you up there so an
antithesis of what an opposition between
individuality
inés own heights right and the universal
universality allgemeine height they says
this is a split in duty a contradiction
within duty look that should be a little
thought-provoking right there wait a
second how can there be a contradiction
within duty or an opposition within duty
well one way is that you have different
duties playing off against each other
and one of them is assumed to be more
important than the others and then those
others are not real duties at all right
or we could go a little bit deeper and
say there's something inherent in the
the notion of duty or obligation or
normativity
is being explored here and that I think
is the right interpretation so he goes
on and he says the duty whose content is
the universal itself directly contains
the nature of pure duty its form and
content are thus completely in a court
so on the one side over here we've got
the universal duty looking at duty
universally we might say or attributing
universality to it and their form and
content are harmonious with each other
they're not striving against each other
and then what else do we have
he says it might seem then that the
action for the general good so general
good is the universal right is to be
preferred to action for the good of the
individual because if we think about the
individual side what we have our
determinant duties and here notice that
he's not talking about duties simply to
others duties also to one's self
these satisfy in some way one's own
interest and so people are suspicious of
that wait a second if you're doing
what's good for you it's not really out
of duty is that it's really just
satisfying your own desires your own
your own wishes making your position
better in relation to the general good
you're not you're not helping the
general good you might actually be
getting in the way of it you might be
taking something away from the general
good so he says that here we go
it might seem the action for the general
good is to be preferred to action for
the good of the individual but this
Universal Duty here is where we have the
unveiling this Universal duty he says is
simply what already exists as an
absolute substance now the way in which
Miller is translating this already
existing for Honda NIST it's already out
there it's already available you could
say and he what he's translating has
absolute substance
is alts on and physique scientist
substance right so we've seen this on
and for Zeke formulation many times
throughout the phenomenology there's
something that's been attained and and
this you know this was an accomplishment
over the course of the development of
human consciousness that's being traced
out here but if we're not at the end
anytime that we have something that is
on infers a akin and for itself it's
always in a certain way not yet there it
it's presenting itself as that but it's
not really that what we'll see how in in
just a moment and he goes on and he says
as law and right right fact when
gazettes nice catch phrase there law and
and right so the normativity that is is
you know supposed to be that of the
society and he says and is valid on its
own account independently of the
individuals knowledge and conviction not
to mention his own immediate interest
now that is a really important
qualification there right traditionally
we understand the universal the general
good the duty towards that as something
that is in fact independent of the
individuals knowledge may be an
individual could be mixed up in relation
to it too bad for that individual
ignorance of the law is no excuse as we
say right and we say that and it goes
back all the way to medieval times also
it doesn't matter about the person's
conviction they may feel that you know
the law the general rule is wrong in
some way but it's still up to them to
follow it it has priority it has
validity it's good right so he goes on
and he says not to mention his own
immediate interest it is therefore
precisely against the form of that duty
that morality in general is directed now
then therefore
does that make sense to you morality
shouldn't morality be on the side of the
universal the general good law and right
well morality here is critical
it doesn't just want to take some sort
of guidance and say okay got it
you know the laws the law is a little
law this is not the sort of day ontology
that is simply rule following for its
own sake this is where you know human
reason particularly practical reason is
by being critical inherently productive
something well worth remembering as we
go through this so he goes on and he
says here we go as regards its content
because this was against the form of
that duty
that too is a determinate content
insofar as the general good as opposed
to the good of the individual now we go
beyond unmasking or unveiling a
genealogical sort of approach you might
say and we note something that is
inherent in the actuality of law and
write law and right have to take place
through some sort of institution and
that institution or whatever you want to
call it the Vere kite the actuality of
it has to be particularized as well you
know you have a city and the city's
general good overrides that of the
individual citizen who decides how that
works it's the mayor or the City Council
or the alder people or whatever it's
going to be have the city planner the
the engineer in some cases will make
decisions and you know we could go on
and on and on with this all the way down
to the level of the social workers and
police officers and people who are
making decisions on the spot in in
ostensibly for the universal for the the
duty to the general good but it's
particularized isn't it and always it
always is it always has to be there's no
way around that
so the general good is not opposed to
the individual good because the
individual good is just selfish and mean
and you know dirty or not pure something
like that
the the universal good the general good
is also opposed to it because it has to
be actual through particularized human
beings it has its own interest like the
interest of remaining able to do its
functions right so we can go on he says
that the general good as far as content
goes is opposed to the good of the
individual consequently its law is one
from which conscience knows itself to be
absolutely free and it gives itself the
authority to add to and take from to
neglect as well as to fulfill it which
means that the norm is not as binding as
we'd like to be and morality reveals to
conscience to this height that it has
choices in front of it it could just say
okay I'm cool with the universal duty
and the general good as configured in
this place seems like things are going
along you know fairly decently
I'm not going to rock the boat I'll
actually you know pay my taxes and
follow the laws and you know upgrade
those who are breaking them and
contribute to my my community in the
ways that they want or it can also say
this community's screwed you know some
people are being treated very unequally
and conscience demands that I take a
stand I have a duty that goes against
the duty that's being enunciated here by
law and right however their embodied so
this is a important turning point isn't
it he goes on and says now here's
another transition then again the above
distinction between duty to the
individual and duty to the universal is
in accordance with the nature
the antithesis as such not something
definitely fixed not something that
holds its position in a static way it
can be not only interpreted in multiple
ways it can also change its
configuration this happens when we start
thinking out implications of actuality
once again so he says here we go the
truth is that what the individual does
for himself also contributes to the
general good satisfying your duties to
yourself as an individual is in fact as
we've seen in previous discussions
contributing to the general good Hegel
is going to stress some of the ways in
which that takes place here he's going
to make that even more particularized or
determinate right clarified so he says
that the more that an individual has
made provision for himself not only is
there a greater possibility of his being
of service to others but his actual
existence itself consists only in his
being and living in contact with others
he goes on in adds his individual
enjoyment essentially has the meaning of
putting what is his own at the disposal
of others and of helping them to obtain
their enjoyment their satisfaction what
would this look like consider you know a
block party and a barbecue everybody
brings their you know their own things
to it but people chip in and maybe get a
keg for beer and somebody is playing
some music and you know they didn't take
like a vote where okay let's let's do a
ballot and what kind of music will we
have and you know whose musical
performance mechanism will we use now
somebody brings out a boombox and or you
know put some stereo speakers in in the
the window and they start playing or
they use their car stereo or something
like that
people start dancing having a good time
and you know somebody's over there on a
grill and maybe they brought the meat
and they're actually letting other
people eat
stuff without insisting that there be an
equal exchange and a reckoning no
they're like hey man you want a
hamburger oh you know you don't eat meat
here's a veggie burger I was thoughtful
and in providing for myself I provided
for you really this is just one of so
many other ways in which we could
express this dynamic as it takes place
it's good to apply this to the classroom
we could apply this to the office we
could apply this to all sorts of places
and situations of life the more that an
individual has made provision for
himself or herself there's a greater
possibility of being of service to
others think about taking care of your
body you know if we're in a crisis
situation like these disaster movies and
I've got to like pull some lady out of a
car and then carry her on my back to the
recently setup medevac well if I'm fat
now to shape because I haven't done my
duty to myself to hit the gym every so
often a gym that I pay for taking time
away from other pursuits then I'm not
gonna pull that lady out of the car and
carry her right we could go on and on
and on
Hegel's not saying that we should be
like totally selfish with the idea that
by being selfish I'm automatically
conferring goods on others he probably
would not buy into the BS ideology of
like job creators or things like that he
would be holding you know CEOs and
ownership of companies very accountable
in ways that we don't do today but he is
saying something here that that I think
many of us can can easily recognize our
actual existence can consist in being
and living in contact with others that
is absolutely essential to the to the
Hegelian way of looking at things
remember that the phenomenology itself
as I've stressed at many points is
fundamentally driven by the desire for
something and it's not a desire for
absolute knowledge it's a desire for on
air-cannon for recognition for
acknowledgement in relation to other
in ways that could be harmonized and
duty is part of that so he goes on and
he says therefore in the fulfillment of
duty to individuals and so to oneself
the duty of the universal is also
fulfilled if we want the real universal
not just the fake static you know
formless bloodless standing over us as
you know like a cop or a rector or
whoever is going to be with all sorts of
rules and laws universal but we want a
more living Universal we need to look to
the individuals to follow out and
fulfill their duties to themselves and
thereby to other people so he goes on
and he says any weighing and comparing
of duties which might be made here would
be tantamount to calculating the
advantage accruing to the universal
though the common good by an action okay
that doesn't sound too bad but then he
says the result would be morality would
be made dependence on the necessary
contingency of insight not everybody has
the same degree or objects of insight
and they says secondly it's precisely
the essence of conscience to have no
truck with this calculating and weighing
of duties and to make its own decision
without reference to any such reasons
and so here this is not the only way in
which this realization could go but in
following out this course the conscience
that is trying to work out what genuine
morality would be for itself is going to
take a rather I don't want it to say
critical perspective but a self
referential perspective where it gets to
decide how it's going to understand
these things for itself and by doing
that it is bringing in the negativity of
consciousness this is you know we see a
lot of hegelian themes working
themselves out in a very determinate way
in this this particular paragraph all of
which is still focused on how we're able
to under
stand duty
you